[Musik]
handy alarm und damit ganz schnell rein
in das gespräch mit peter tschentscher
direkt am kanzleramt denn paul
ronzheimer empfängt live infos aus den
parteigremien jetzt das politische
berlin dass läuft sich jetzt richtig
warm jetzt haben die gremien sitzung
begonnen bei der spd und vor allen
dingen bei der cdu und von dort hast du
auf dein handy infos bekommen sagt uns
welche das sind vielleicht die
spannendsten gremiensitzungen die es
seit vier jahren gegeben hat hier
entscheidet sich was in deutschland
passieren wird am ende und gerade eben
hat sich armin laschet der kanzler der
kanzlerkandidat der union geäußert und
er hat ein sehr sehr spannenden satz
gesagt er hat nämlich gesagt in den
medien würde geschrieben dass er ein
regierungsanspruch dass wir so
formuliert dass ein regierungsanspruch
formuliert haben er sagt aber das sei
nicht der fall
und er verweist auf die ergebnisse und
ein neues parteien system also die enge
ergebnisse würden zeigen dass ist ein
neues parteien system gibt aber das
bedeutet nicht gleichzeitig dass man
ansprüche formulieren also man nimmt
etwas zurück von gestern abend am ende
zumindest das war die nach wahrnehmung
der hat armin laschet gesagt wir erheben
einen regierungsanspruch jetzt sagt er
nein das sei nicht der fall aber es gebe
ein neues parteien system gleichzeitig
hat armin laschet in dieser sitzung klar
gemacht dass er nicht
fraktionsvorsitzender werden will dass
er die gespräche aus der situation des
parteivorsitzenden führen will das
bedeutete am ende rang brinker aus der
unionsfraktionschef kann drinbleiben
silvia dreher hat sich dort ebenfalls
geäußert aus dem präsidium sie hat auch
noch einmal kritisiert dass sozusagen
dieser eindruck dass man jetzt den
anspruch stellt nicht gut sei das läuft
jetzt eine hitzige debatte
gleichzeitig scheint es so dass die
union geschlossen ist dass man nicht auf
den vorsitzenden los geht sondern dass
man taktisch wartet was jetzt passiert
in diesen gesprächen um jamaika in
diesem krimi in diesem kampf in diesem
krieg um die beste koalition für
deutschland hoch spontan in news
wirklich aus einem wir wollen es etwa
ist ein bisschen paul eingewöhnt teil
gerne versuchen es weiter man könne es
nicht so richtig die cdu macht sich
jetzt schon deutlich kleiner als gestern
so breitbeinig wie mann der gestern
aufgetreten ist was wir jetzt alle
erstaunt hat steht man jetzt heute da
nicht mehr da genauso ist es kein das
ist das spannende also wie will man
jetzt in diese gespräche reingehen das
bedeutet auch dass man am ende
vielleicht erstmal will dass die ampel
scheitern könnte bevor man in jamaica
reingeht
[Musik]